well out of a rare big tree for free
speech comedian and author Constantine
kissing went viral after taking on woke
culture and an Oxford Union speech Let's
have a look at some of the highlights
this country is responsible for two
percent of global carbon emissions
which means that if Britain was to sink
into the sea right now it would make
absolutely no difference to the issue of
climate change you know why because the
future of the climate is going to be
decided in Asia and in Latin America by
poor people who couldn't give about
saving the planet there is only one
thing we can do in this country to stop
climate change and that is to make
scientific and technological
breakthroughs that will create the clean
energy that is not only clean but also
cheap and the only thing that wokeness
has to offer in exchange is to brainwash
Bright Young Minds like you to believe
that you are victims to believe that you
have no agency to believe that what you
must do to improve the world is to
complain
is to protest is to throw soup on
paintings we know that the way to
improve the world is to work is to
create it is to build
and the problem with work culture is
that it's trained too many young minds
like yours to forget about that
[Applause]
yes the slow hand clap that's what every
comedian works for peace let me do it
faster
um I've done nostril Union tough ground
normally but you actually want a lot of
them over they were quite respectful uh
and I think I was but you were probably
a bit surprised by the response uh it's
gone viral Global this all over America
as well because it really resonated with
people I think rather like me where you
know I'm not right wing I'm not
left-wing I'm kind of slightly Center I
guess politically about stuff a liberal
more than not but I find this Ultra woke
mentality so illiberal that it borders
on the very fascism they profess to hate
most so to see you go into the lion's
den a bit with all these woke students
and actually what I thought was
impressive about it Constantine was the
way you didn't demonize them and maybe
that is the way to to progress and get
this woke nonsense dealt with properly
is that you don't demonize them you
actually show them a better way I think
so and like you I identify as
politically non-binary peers and and so
that that's angle I was approaching from
look the fact is both you and I know
that when we were 18 20 we were idiots
as well and we were very cocky and sure
of ourselves and we thought we knew the
answers to everything what we didn't
have was the internet to brainwash us
and we didn't have this very powerful
ideology actually wokeness isn't
ideology and there's some very strong
Concepts behind it but that all aside I
thought I found that I had a very
interesting encounter because you you
did you once have seen this but we had
to wait quite a long time before the
debate started and I actually was
talking to one of the students in the
bar and she she couldn't believe that I
even thought the woke people existed
like to her this was unicorns but she
came up to me after the debate and asked
for a selfie and that's kind of what I
thought really summed up the whole
experience you've got to remember these
are young people in the mind they're
open to persuasion we got to make better
arguments and I think antagonizing
people and we've all been there you and
I and everything else you know my
journey with my show at trigonometry
it's been an evolution too I haven't
started out like this necessarily but
what I've come to now and maybe it's
being a father of a young child now as
well I'm starting to see that you know
these are kids and we we have a
responsibility to persuade them to
convince them with rational argument and
look when you're speaking to Bright
people like the ones at Oxford you've
got a chance I mean one of the worst
aspects of wokery is the way that people
now feel too afraid to express opinions
and it's becoming a real thing where
people you know I name Joan Collins on
it didn't want to say what she thought a
woman was and she's one of my favorite
people in the world Joan and obviously
knows what she believes a woman is but
didn't want to raise her head over a
parapet just to be shot down by the
trans Lobby or whatever whatever Lobby
it may be at any given moment there's
this mob mentality you if you don't
agree with me you must be canceled
immediately shame vilified JK Rowling
whoever it may be how we got to this
place what's fueling it how do we deal
with it well first of all I know that
you're shocked by and I think a lot of
people in the west are shocked but
actually someone who grew up in the
Soviet Union this is very familiar I
mean this is exactly what we had and
that's one of the reasons I'm in this
country is my grandfather said the wrong
thing and was forced into Exile so this
is actually if you think about human
history pretty standard we just didn't
expect it to be happening in the 21st
century and I think technology is a big
part of it social media allows people to
mob other people well the fuels also
tribalism it fuels this sort of
righteous indignation the victimhood and
people get that don't forget there's
also oh there's real power and the power
actually manifests itself from the mob
going to corporate world and demanding
that they fire people and get rid of
people who don't agree with their view
exactly and I think a lot of people
particularly and you know this isn't an
attack but you know if you don't have a
lot of meaning in your own life this is
a way to get some meaning because you
tap this thing on your phone or on your
keyboard and suddenly a famous person is
getting canceled I think that's a big
part of it but as I say I'm just you'd
frankly point out I think the solution
here is to be reasonable to talk to
people to try and persuade them while
also of course we've got to stand up and
not allow these cancellations to happen
and that means that you know TV
producers and big corporations they have
to step up as well I mean I was forced
out of my last job for disbelieving Mega
Mark which seems Preposterous now given
the nonsense that comes out of her mouth
but that showed me that when the mob
attacked the corporate world the
corporate world will often bow to the
Mob because actually they're just
terrified of the consequences are
terrified of losing advertising Revenue
sponsors and so on that's the way they
do it it's very well marshaled and well
organized albeit there are quite a small
number of people they're just well
organized yeah and they're able to
create the illusion that there is lots
of them because on social media you can
get a lot of traction with with not a
lot but I think you're right and I think
the fact is that we're building an
alternative ecosystem now shows like
mine on YouTube and uh there's going to
be companies that are making products
that don't care if you're woke or not
advertisers that are not interested did
in the stuff and I actually said this on
Twitter today I think the future isn't
woke or anti-work the Futures post work
we just got to move past this well the
trouble is the word has become toxic
originally work meant that you were just
more alert to racial and social
injustice yeah well we would all sign up
to that anyone with a brain and a
conscience would say yeah I can sign up
to it but it's been hijacked yes by the
ultra wokies you basically are a former
fascist who are using this for their own
ends and I think that's why both all of
us have actually just got to move past
it and go this has appeared in human
history which was pretty stupid let's
move on let's see how we can work
together and but for Fears we've got to
change the way that we have political
conversations in this country because
that's where this polarization is coming
from and we carry on down this path it's
very dangerous well that's so tribal as
well and toxic and Hyper partisan fueled
Again by social media people don't want
to admit anything wrong with their side
right and it's so refreshing when
occasionally you hear one of them do it
you know you think wow there's someone
prepared to criticize their own side as
if it's somehow a football team and you
can't admit to giving a way of booking
or something so why yeah how do we get
to that place in a democracy the whole
point of democracy is that actually we
have a debate and we reach consensus
well right and that's why I quite often
do is my audience grows and expands I go
out of my way to annoy some of them to
just kind of position myself correctly
because I don't want to be playing to
any Eco chamber I'm trying to just be
honest about what I think
trigonometry and you're going to go
gangbusters on the back of this viral
clip I mean you surprised by how it's
taken off I mean it's going to sound
arrogant but I'm not I felt pretty good
on the night particularly you know no
notice I noticed yeah well yeah I I
can't I'm pretty clear on what I think
about it now you know we spend five
years on trigonometry interviewing all
sorts of Fascinating People you know the
Douglas Murray's the Jordan Petersons
lots of people on the left trying to
understand what's going on because you
know the story of us is it's two
comedians didn't really know what was
going on but what we felt was in comedy
there was a lot of hypersensitivity and
outright censorship going on we can
understand where it was coming from so
we thought let's talk to people who are
smarter than us who can explain what's
going on and now I'm pretty clear on
what I think well you've been trying to
get me on trigonometry for a while when
are you coming now I will now publicly
agree and we're going to do it at our
mutual friends restaurant in Portugal in
Kensington Saturday I'll be there let's
put the world to rights Constantine
congratulations brilliant speech and
I'll see you there